the Constitution is kind of kicked
around like a worn-out football I'd
suggest it's stuffing is is leaking out
at torn scenes whether we look to the
bailout or the contemplated legislation
of more stimulus packages there is very
little regard in Washington for the
constitutionality of these measures
there's very little debate and it seems
reasonable thinking back to the fact
that our Constitution after all was to
be an empire of reason it does seem
reasonable to ask that if we are going
to do these things and make judgment
calls as a people that we ought to
constitutionalize them before doing so
or else what we do like any law that is
flagrantly violated it becomes a
laughingstock right it becomes a thing
not to be considered at all and
therefore if that happens it is
impossible to venerate a document that
is entirely made into a political
football that's made into something that
is one day one thing and another day
another thing the founders believed that
our Constitution had to be venerated
because of its constancy right when
Jefferson had the ill-begotten idea of
having a constitution for each
generation he was rebuked by some of his
colleagues saying if that's the case how
will people be able to venerate it if we
have something new every generation what
about the constancy what about the
longevity of that document Abraham
Lincoln in a speech given before he was
30 years old indicated that the current
dilemma in 1838 was that the founders of
the country were literally dying each
day not unlike that of those who today
are falling at the rate of thousands per
day who fought in World War two so you
have your pillars of Liberty falling
those reminders those living reminders
to the American people of what the
principles of the American Revolution
were Abraham Lincoln said with that
happening all around us what are we to
do to remember the Constitution
and he said what you have to do is to
teach it to young people you have to
instruct it whether from the pulpit or
two little babies you have to you have
to keep citizens attuned to this in a
way that it becomes for them something
that is truly sacred I think that that's
our task today I think that it's
certainly not too late to to inject this
into our public discourse in fact i
think it is precisely the time that we
must have that and to insist that in
further debates of whether it's in the
economic and financial crisis or in
matters of war and peace or in matters
of how we're going to be crafting our
budget that the Constitution and the
constitutionality of each of these
things is front and center